all right here it is flopping the most  caring [ __ ] into all the sports all  right so think about it what does a  karen do lie about being attacked  pretend something happened that did not  then try to get the authorities on her  side i guess being a karen is not the  exclusive territorial the white wall  your favorite athlete hits the ground  like he got shot even though nobody  touched him he's doing the same thing so  if you falsely accuse somebody you're  fouling you should go to jail for that  or be suspended free the weed man lock  up the flopper preach and our day taking  the charge was honored should me an hour  day game theory sunday nights want me to  fill this in  i need help in the front on hbo max  you